some breaking news just reaching us here
at dw former u.s police officer derrick
chauvin has been sentenced to 22 and a
half
years for the murder of george floyd the
court first heard impact statements from
mr floyd's family
they called for the maximum jail time
for chauvin
uh the judge passed sentence uh for the
most serious charge
joven is still facing civil rights
charges
dw correspondent stephan simons is in
minneapolis in front of the courthouse
where the sentencing is happening
welcome stefan uh so talk us through the
reactions to this sentence
well uh reactions here right after it
was announced that derek showman will
receive or will go to prison for two
22 years and a half were subdued
actually very calm
now you can maybe hear this and you can
see it in the background stepping out of
the picture here
there's a small group of activists or
protesters
pro george floyd protesters
and there is actually more press there
if it looks
as a bigger crowd that's not the case
this is more press than actually
protesters and they're a little bit
agitated and that has something to do
that
some people allegedly white
people are asking questions they don't
want to hear one way or another
22.5 years for derek shoving and where
does this settle
40 years would have been the maximum
possible 12 and a half would have been
the
minimum possible the prosecutor wanted
30 years
the prosecutor wanted 30 years and the
defense wanted
mr chauvin actually to walk free
probation and walk out of here
with the uh days kept in prison already
counted and as a credit for him now
cahill the judge
cahill came down with 22.5 years and the
reason for this
are the aggregating factors which he had
decided on about a month ago that they
are valid for example
that derek chauvin showed a
specific cruelty when he was for nine
minutes and 25 seconds on
george floyd's neck and that he did what
he did in the presence of miners of
children
and so on um so there you have it 22
point
five years but here's the caveat is this
over
now no it is not why two reasons
a there is an appeal expected defense
has about 90 days three months time to
file an appeal and to
appeal this judgment from judge cahill
here these state
judges state charges number two reason
number two is
there is a federal case still pending
against um
mr chauvin and that is a civil rights
case from
federal prosecutors there's not even a
court date for this now so
everything all things considered chauvin
and court and how many years he goes to
prison etc etc
is still an ongoing story right so 22
and a half years for the murder of
george
floyd you you talked us through the
immediate reaction there
outside the courthouse uh is it too
early to to have heard from the floyd
family or indeed
the chauvin legal team
yeah um it is too early the floyd family
has
spoken during what is called a victim
statements period where the victims
could
could make impact statements and the two
brothers of george floyd
uh they were speaking before the
sentence was announced
and and they had and that was quite
impressive a lot of trouble actually to
stay uh on on on point very emotional
trouble to speak had to pause many times
and wipe away tears
they talked about the impact for the
family and
one brother said and asked and backed or
pleaded with the court saying
i asked you to give him the
possible maximum sentence whatever is
legally possible
please throw the book at him that gives
the family closure we expecting the
family to speak out in a little bit
not in sure exactly when this will
happen but i assume it will happen
and then we'll know more on this now
towards the crowd here
in minneapolis um there is no riots or
anything expected here there will be
maybe a shouting here shouting there and
a little march down the street
or around the hennepin government center
but that's about it
all right stephen simons in minneapolis
thank you so much
you